let's do some more non-homogeneous
equations so let's take the same problem
but we'll change the right hand side
because i think you know how to solve
the left essentially the homogeneous
version so same problem as we did in the
last video the second derivative of y
minus three times the first derivative
of y
minus four times the function and now in
the last example we had the the
non-homogeneous part was three e to the
two x but we're tired of dealing with
exponent functions so let's make it a
trigonometric function so let's say it
equals 2 sine of x
so the first step you do is is what we
did what we've been doing is you take
the character you essentially solve the
homogeneous equation so this left hand
side is equal to 0. you do that by
getting the characteristic equation r
squared minus 3r minus
4 is equal to 0 you get the solutions
r is equal to 4 r is equal to -1 and
then you get that general solution we
did this in the last video
you get the general solution
of the homogeneous
maybe we'll call this the homogeneous
solution
y homogeneous we got with c one e to the
four x
plus
c2
e to the minus x
and that's all in good but in order to
get the general solution
of this non-homogeneous equation i have
to take the solution of the homogeneous
equation if this were equal to zero and
then add that to a particular solution
that satisfies this equation that
satisfies uh that that when you when you
take the second derivative minus three
times the first minus four times the
function i actually get two sine of x
and here once again we'll use
undetermined coefficients and
undetermined coefficients you just think
to yourself
what function when i take it second and
first derivatives and add and subtract
multiples of them to each other will i
get sine of x
well two functions end up with sine of x
when you take first and second
derivatives and that's sine and cosine
of x
so it's a good guess and that's really
what you're doing in the method of
undetermined coefficients you take a
guess of a particular solution and then
you solve for the undetermined
coefficients so let's say that our guess
is
y
y is equal to
i don't know some coefficient times sine
of x
and if this was sine of 2x i'd put a
times sine of 2x here
just because i want its derivatives to i
still want no matter what happens here i
want the sine of two x's or maybe
cosines of two x's to still exist if
this was a sine of 2x there's nothing i
could do to a sine of x or nothing at
least trivial that i could do with sine
of x it would end up with a sine of 2x
so whatever is here i want here
plus
cosine of 2x plus b some coefficient
undetermined coefficient times cosine of
x and once again this was sine of 2x i'd
want a cosine of 2x here
so let's figure out its first and second
derivatives so the first derivative
of this
y
prime
is equal to
a
cosine of x
cosine derivative is minus sign so minus
b
sine of x
and then the second derivative i'll
write down here
the second derivative
is equal to what derivative of cosine is
minus sine so minus
a sine of x
minus b cosine of x
minus v cosine of x
i think you're starting to see the
hardest thing in most differential
equations problems is not making
careless mistakes it's a lot of algebra
and and and a lot of fairly basic
calculus but and the real trick is to
not make careless mistakes
every time i say that i tend to make one
so i'm going to focus extra right now so
anyway let's take these and substitute
them back into
into this dif this non-homogenous
equation let's see if i can solve for a
and b
so the second derivative is that
i'm going to add from that i'm going to
let me just rewrite it just so that you
see what i'm doing so i'm going to take
the second derivative y prime prime so
that's
minus a
sine
of x minus b
cosine of x
i'm going to add minus 3 times the first
derivative to that and i'm going to
write the signs under the sines and the
cosines under the cosine so minus 3
times this so the sign is let's see it's
plus 3b sine of x
so
b
sine of x
minus 3 times this so minus
three
a
minus three a
cosine of x
and then minus four times
four times our original function so
minus four minus 4
a sine of x
right minus 4 times that minus 4 times
this
minus 4
b
cosine of x
and when i take the sum of all of those
when i when i that's essentially the
left-hand side of this equation when i
take the sum of all of that
that is equal to 2 sine of x
i could have written them out in a line
but it would just be more confusing and
now this is not this makes it easy to
add up the sine of x's and the cosine of
x's
so if i add up all the coefficients on
the sine of x i get minus a plus 3b
minus 4a
so that looks like
minus 5a
plus 3b
sine of x
plus and now what are the coefficients
here
what are all the coefficients here i
have minus b and then i have
another minus four b so minus five b and
then minus three a so minus three a
minus five b
ran out of space cosine of x
this is the cosine of x should go right
here
so anyway how do i solve for a and b
well i have the 5 minus 5a plus 3b is
equal to whatever coefficients in front
of sine of x here so minus 5a plus 3b
must be equal to 2.
and then minus 3a minus 5b is the
coefficient on cosine of x although i
kind of squeezed in the cosine of x here
right so this is this must be equal to
whatever the coefficient on cosine of x
is on the right hand side well the
cosine the coefficient of cosine of x on
the right hand side is zero so that sets
up a system of two unknowns with two
equations a linear system
so we get
minus
five a
plus
three b
is equal to two
and we get minus three a
minus five
b
is equal to
zero
equal to zero and let's see if i can
simplify this a little bit see this is a
system of two unknowns two equations if
i multiply the top equation by
five
thirds
right
actually now let me multiply well let me
multiply the top equation by five thirds
i get
minus 25
over three
a
plus
five
b
is equal to five thirds times this
five thirds times two is ten thirds
ten thirds and the bottom equation is i
have minus three a
minus five b
is equal to zero let's add the two
equations i get ten thirds is equal to
these cancel out
and let's see that's minus 25
over 3
minus 9 over 3
right
minus 9
over 3
a
is equal to 10 thirds it's getting a
little bit messier than i like but
we'll solder on
so let's see minus 5 25
minus
what's minus 25 minus 9 so that is 34.
so we get 34
over 3a is equal to 10
over 3. or let's see we can get rid of
we can multiply both sides by 3
divide both sides by 34 a is equal to 10
over 34 which is equal to 5
over 17. nice ugly number 5 over 17 and
now we can solve for b
so
let's see minus 3 times a this color is
nauseating me
minus 3 times a
5 over 17
minus 5
b
is equal to 0
so that's what minus
15 over 17 is equal to minus is equal to
plus 5b
i just took this put on the right hand
side and then divide both sides
by
divide both sides
by 5.
actually let me make sure oh you know
what i realize i made the coast mistake
here minus 25 minus 9 that's minus 34
over 3 so minus 34 a is equal to 10 a is
equal to minus 10 over 34 or minus 5
over 17
so minus 3 times minus 5 over 17. so
that's equal to plus
5 15 over 17 is equal to plus 5b right
and then we get b
is equal to 3
over 17. that was harry
and notice the hard part was
not losing your negative signs but
anyway we now have our particular
solution to this
right our particular solution is
let me try to write in a non-nauseating
color although i think i picked a
nauseating one the particular solution
is a
minus 5 over 17
sine of x right that was a coefficient
on sine of x plus b
plus 3 over 17
times cosine of x
and if we look at our original problem
the general solution now to this
non-homogeneous equation would be this
which is the general solution to the
homogeneous equation which we've done
many videos on plus now our particular
solution that we solved using the method
of undetermined coefficients so if you
just take that and add it to that you're
done and i'm out of time see you in the
next video